Щодо питання про судноплавство в Азовському морі
між Україною і Росією було укладено кілька угод.
Але ключовим серед них є Договір про співробітництво
у використанні Азовського моря і Керченської протоки.
Згідно з цим документом, торговельні та військові судна обох країн,
які експлуатуються в некомерційних цілях,
мають право вільного судноплавства.
Україна не порушила жодного права на відміну від Росії.
Україна мала повне право на прохід своїх військових кораблів
через Керченську протоку і далі до Маріуполя в Азовському морі -
за угодою 2003 року, яку ніхто не скасовував.
Росія жодного разу не говорила, щ
о вона має щось проти,
буде змінювати чи відмовляється приймати цей договір до виконання.
Єдина зачіпка у російської сторони може бути така.
Вона вже заявила, що українські кораблі
пройшли в Керченську протоку,
зачепивши шматочок
територіальних вод, які Росія вважає своїми,
а саме: територіальних вод Криму.
Але, з точки зору міжнародного права,
Крим НЕ є російською територією, а тому будь-який міжнародний суд визнає:
в даному випадку дії України
повністю відповідають всім вимогам морського законодавства.
Інформація, що з'явилася в деяких російських ЗМІ
про те, що військові кораблі можуть користуватися протокою лише за згодою обох сторін -
не відповідає дійсності. В угоді йдеться виключно
про кораблі третіх країн. І як Росія, так і Україна до них не належать.
Якщо користуватися звичайним морським правом,
то є частина моря, яка є виключно економічною зоною,
виключною зоною, де є інтереси лише однієї чи іншої сторони.
І саме ця угода запровадила поняття -
внутрішні води обох країн.
Тобто право з боку Росії блокувати вхід
на територію Азовського моря воєнних кораблів третіх країн.
Якщо хочеться комусь денонсувати щось, то вже краще денонсувати угоду по Азову,
яка нам була більш невигідна, ніж вигідна.
Але, на думку професора з міжнародного права в Університеті бундесверу
Даніеля Еразмуса Кана, мова в даному випадку навіть
не йде про територіальні води або двосторонні угоди.
Існує так званий режим користування морськими протоками,
визначений Конвенцією ООН з морського права
від 1982 року, яку підписали як Росія, так і Україна.
Він передбачає, що на протоки, що з'єднують частини відкритого моря
і навіть повністю перекриваються територіальним водами прибережних держав,
поширюється право транзитного проходу, яким користуються всі судна,
включно з військовими кораблями.
Тож, Україна діяла повністю у відповідності з міжнародним правом,
впевнений німецький експерт.